in this video we're going to try to
figure out what 0.6 or 6 tenths divided
by 2 is and I'll give you a little bit
of a hint
we have 6/10 plotted on the number line
right over here and so one way to think
about it is if I wanted to go from 0 to
6 tenths in two jumps how big would each
of those jumps have to be pause this
video and try to figure that out on your
own before we work through it together
alright so as I mentioned one way to
think about it is how can I go from 0 to
6 tenths in 2 jumps to equal jumps I
should say well if we just eyeball it
right over here I could do one jump like
that and then another jump like that so
I did one jump and then two jumps and so
one way to think about it is we've had
we've divided 6 tenths into two jumps
and each of those jumps are how far well
each of those jumps are 1 2 3 tenths so
this is three tenths or I could write it
like this 3 tenths we have another one
to three tenths so this is going to be
equal to three tenths and we've thought
about it in other ways if you have six
of something and you divide it by two
you're going to have two groups of three
of that something so if you have six
tenths and you want to put it into two
equal groups well each of those groups
are going to be three tenths